well we've been filming all day and I've
had my Americas on you should take those
home man I get a few like side glances
from people that are like oh you're one
of those guys so we were talking about
this today in the van I don't appreciate
that I feel like patriotism has been
co-opted by one you know half of the
country so this whole party yeah I'm a
patriot I mean I was telling you the
story the other day when when uh my my
son had his friends over uh to the house
and we were going to watch the USA
Netherlands game uh the World Cup uh USA
Netherlands game his two buddies I won't
name them uh we're like yeah we're gonna
go for the Netherlands and I was like
wait what what do you mean you're going
for the Netherlands and I found myself
getting genuinely pissed off because
there's a bunch of crap first of all kid
tell me one thing about the Netherlands
point to the Netherlands on a map we'll
see okay so that was the point I was
making yeah exactly right here's a map
by the way he probably pointed right up
Netherlands they would have pointed it
right out there's still a geographer
smarter than we are so I'm saying like
they're in geography right now [__]